qui dit campagne électorale dit
forcément on s'en rend compte sondages à
tout va à six mois de la présidentielle
le quotidien ouest france a donc décidé
de ne plus rien y est relayé ses
intentions de vote un geste fort est
plutôt rare dans les médias pour le
rédacteur en chef ces sondages détourne
de l'essentiel
david khalifa
environ 630 mille exemplaires vendus par
jour ouest france est cette année une
nouvelle fois le quotidien le plus vendu
au sein de l'hexagone et pourtant le
rédacteur en chef du journal a pris
cette décision pour le moins étonnante
il ne publiera aucun sondage avant les
présidentielles s'il considère à les
sondeurs comme des professionnels
françois-xavier lefranc n'acceptent plus
cette avalanche d'intentions de vote qui
tombe sur les citoyens mais il refuse
surtout d'alimenter les débats
médiatiques écouter ouest france ne
participera pas à la grande manif ne
réalisera aucun sondage politique avant
la présidentielle et évitera de perdre
du temps à commenter ceux des autres
nous nous consacrerons reportage à l'anc
est au plus près de celles et ceux qui
ont des choses à dire une prise de
position qui s'explique également par la
montée en puissance des partis extrêmes
françois-xavier lefranc souhaiterait
davantage de reportages sur le terrain
pour aller à la rencontre des français
beaucoup plus révélateur pour lui que
ces sondages il ajoute que ce recours
systématique évitez également de se
pencher sérieusement sur les programmes
des candidats en tout cas ce risque
éditorial pris par ouest-france présage
une élection présidentielle plus que
jamais indécise